we decided that if we want to become the
best in this game like we need to find
people that are fully committed
to valerian and so that's when we built
the team
how many are going to be on that peak
one pulls the off and that means two
more are going to come around coming in
for shazam
he's feeling it he's smoked out gonna
hit up third one without even seeing him
when i look at him in cs his play style
was not gonna be good for lance
uh his tens he's got the frenzy and he's
all up and moves his face and he's
getting a jumping one as well on the
thief
i said this the first time i called tens
this is his world
and we're just living in it i think
obviously the sentinels have like
amazing players individually but
i feel like what they do is very uh
predictable
it's up to dapper there oh
whoa what the hell was that from dapper
yeah scary stuff you're trying to take
that opening jewel oh hello tents gonna
find
max oh my word plastic follow-up onto
doma and they're looking good to try to
finish this one shazam has to go to the
side gets concussed
has to be great on his first one oh my
god how old has he done that
the rebel class from shazam is
phenomenal
today sentinels are the reykjavik
champions and the best valorant team
in the world but a year ago if you said
this was going to be the team that
lifted the game's first international
trophy
nobody would have believed you sentinel
spent the last year proving everyone
wrong by
dominating north america and no matter
what challenges they faced or whatever
people said about them
they just kept winning but to fully
understand their story
we have to go back way back to before
valrant even came out
the man who had become sentinel's igl
was struggling
shazam was a newly teamless out-of-luck
cs go player and
after a decade of seeing almost no
results he saw valard as a chance to
finally
leave cs behind we could kind of see the
way
north american cs go was trending with
the exclusivity on the leagues
and the different leagues fighting it
didn't look like there was a future for
nacs go
shazam reached out to riot hoping to
participate in the game's alpha test and
luckily for him his wish was granted
shazam loved valorant and he saw a
future in the game
but that future involved a team backing
him up
first shazam brought in his former
teammate sick who also struggled to find
a permanent home in cs
but they still needed three more players
we decided that if we want to become the
best in this game like
we need to find people that are fully
committed to valerian
and so that's when we built the team and
in april 2020 they announced that team
but everyone was kind of caught off
guard by some of sentinel's roster
choices
zombs a former apex legends pro was
already playing under the sentinel's
banner before switching to valorant
and sinatra the reigning overwatch
league mvp and world champion shocked
the esports world by
signing with sentinels too people were
confused when they saw this roster
and many doubted them from the get-go
early on it seemed like most of the top
valorem players were former cs go
players
meanwhile here with sentinels signing
former apex and overwatch pros
no one really knew how it was going to
work out and to top it all off
shazam took the reins as the team's igl
for the first time in his career
so he knew there was going to be some
challenges there wasn't worry about like
how long it would take to teach them
fundamentals like rotations
i remember the first day of practice we
got into scrims and i realized like
these guys
don't understand what defaulting is like
in overwatch you're constantly moving
constantly doing something
and explain the concept of hey you got
to sit here and do nothing while other
people take control of a different part
of map
just to account for something that the
other team might do like you just got to
be patient
and so there's definitely uh growing
pains at the start
and a whole process to learn the team
later found their fifth member in dapper
a young up-and-coming cs player who was
never really given the opportunity to
shine
in tier 1 cs go at first things didn't
look so good for sentinels
marv gets the off and that surely is
going to be too much now for sinatra
he needs to go huge here with a one
versus three he's down to 45
hp but he can't even get past marv as
the first hurdle
faze clan gonna take this one 13 to
seven what an incredible
second half it was from them they looked
impeccable
on defense but as the months went on
sentinels improved
they picked up wins against basically
every other major team in the region
and by the end of the year they were the
best team in na
sick the battle stage to win this one
out players going to be located on the
site sick now in a 1v1
oh no and sick sick i cannot believe it
sick gets
it and your champions of pax arena
are sentinels that could be the
tournament
this could be all lit ordeal he has to
come up big he's not able to make these
shots and that's going to be it
sentinels are going to be your 30 bomb
gg champions 13 to 10.
and here comes a counter rocket kapoor
who's trying to do it but shazam
shuts it down 13-8 sentinels are going
to lock up the final na ignition series
event
of the year but it wasn't just their
mechanical skill and teamwork that was
making headlines
amidst all the wins sentinels were kind
of trolling the competition
they bm'd other teams so hard that
dapper even got a
death threat from a fan back in december
and although some valorant fans saw them
as the scenes of villains
sentinels didn't care they'd already
beaten the haters once so
all they had to do was just keep winning
but
you are staring at death's door at this
point of your rock it's a cold peek
around this corner
and we could be looking at it that's
right folks gg
sentinels back to their winning ways as
they walk away
with the jbl quantum cup
trophy but just days before masters one
on march 9th
one of sentinel's core members came
under fire sinatra's ex-girlfriend cleo
hernandez
accused him of sexually assaulting and
abusing her for over a year
and included audio and message logs in a
twitter post that she shared that night
both riot and sentinels launched
investigations and sinatra has since
been suspended from competitive play
until september 10th of this year
for failing to fully comply with them
neither investigation has publicly
released any ruling regarding
hernandez's allegations
but for the other members of sentinels
it was a mad scramble they had
one day to find a replacement they
managed to pick up tens on a one month
loan as a last-minute stand-in
but tens had recently benched himself
from cloud9's valerant team in favor of
content creation
so no one was really sure how this was
going to work out see
even before his valorent days tenz was
known for choking
in csgo an awp
for the youngster already a man crossing
over
my e is stuck in the mud here oboe
looking to lead the way but rush is
there to
cut off the head presence towards b
though on a cloud nine on the get-go and
automatic gets the shot onto marquis
as well able to chime in and again for
the player we
are hoping to expect more of and
actually we're expecting more we're not
hoping to we do expect more out of him
he's not really been able to live up to
it so far in the pro league
once again doubt overshadowed sentinel's
future
but tens was one of the most exciting
players valorent had ever seen
and with him on their side sentinels
looked unstoppable
got the frenzy and he's got a kill man
all up and moves his face and he's
getting a jumping one as well on the
thief
i said this the first time i called tens
this is his world
and we're just living in it now that
nitro is thrown up now they might have a
chance at something stick with an
excellent curveball austin who drops
three members remaining on the side
hundred thieves make that two as
sentinels look to put
hundred thieves away steel and he go no
it's just steel tent tens with the
bladestorm looking to take down the
remaining member steal what magic do you
have in your hat it's not going to be
enough a flawless round
a statement made sentinels 200 thieves
and sentinels start to circle they start
to enclose around the phase players
they smell blood it's in the water and
they want to finish it off intense
is looking to do it in style mark two hp
left
here comes a dagger with his name on it
but it's gonna be sick
who's gonna get it done and that's a
wrap 3-0
grand finals sentinels are the champions
for the n a masters here in ballaran
and it looked good all the way through
before they even had time to celebrate
their win though
sentinels were thrown right back into
the grueling qualification process
this time they are trying to qualify for
iceland valerian's first ever
international land
as well as just effie's with the sheriff
no less good for one but no he gets
cleaned up ladies and gentlemen from top
to bottom sentinels
dominate v1 and they are your challenger
stage 2
champions sentinels dumpstered n a and
with tens on their side
they were among the favorites going into
iceland despite their dominance though
the haters return see like we already
said iceland was valerian's first ever
international land
all the best teams from all over the
world would be there and
nobody knew what to expect because
they'd never played against each other
before
but i do think europe is a bit better
like
i think obviously the sentinels have
like amazing players
individually but i feel like what they
do is very
predictable
tense is a lot of work on his hands here
he's not gonna be able to feel any
damage it's up to dapper there
oh whoa
what the hell was that from dapper
sentinel started the event off with a
win against fnatic but
it wasn't easy both maps were extremely
close and
things weren't supposed to get easier
from there
but it turns out they did postponers
watches ahem all
over the top he gets two shuts out again
and then the that will force sentinels
to surrender
the a site the thing is if they use that
much
but then they don't have too much to
take the site over intense continues to
go to work
yeah he does two kills on the board
already
before they've even gone to the site and
oh it just doesn't stop here
sentinels another prime gaming flawless
for them it's been so many in this half
still has the paint shells still has the
satchel
can say find the first player yes he can
there goes lakia a right click on the
paint shell
sick nails the clutch 1v2 no problem at
all for him
and he's going to get peppered from all
sides and there we go sentinels take
down newton on map 2 on haven
13-4 to take the series to move forward
to the grand finals
and they are going to be knocking down
newton sentinels
bulldozed their way through vikings and
new turn but in the grand finals
they had to face a familiar foe going
against sentinels once again this time
we get
to have a little bit of a some revenge
probably um
hopefully we're going to make it we're
going to take maps off them and
hopefully we're going to take 3-0 off
them
fnatic was the only team that really
tested sentinels all tournament
and their rematch could go the distance
and there's no real opportunity to go
anywhere else at this point they're just
gonna
send it with the dash darker with a nice
opening but needs two
more to go and it's gonna be difficult
to find those it's now just doma with
the ghost
sentinels will be toying with durka and
in fact they're just gonna finish things
off
the opening pistol round will be won by
sentinels
just needs that one frag oh
did as well the dash comes through he's
gonna whip doesn't matter
shazam finds another the updraft over
the top here as he tries to find the law
my god
yeah there's lack of util now at a we
have a better chance to hit a
but they don't have a read on where any
of the fanatic players are yet
sentinels go in completely dry thinking
they can walk it through and tens has to
do a bunch of work to bring this one
back
yeah scary stuff you're trying to take
that opening jewel oh hello tens is
going to find
magnus oh my word fantastic follow-up
onto doma
lee's fanatic truly rocked after that
they have very little to work with now
looking good to try to finish this one
shazam has to go to the side guess
concussed
has to be great on his first point oh my
god how old has he done that
the rebel clans from shazam is
phenomenal in
in the window he'll get caught shazam's
creeping forward
oh he finally times starker
they're running through sonar up dome
was close they don't know oh my god he
gets blessed
the team flash the team flash magnum's
in the smoke here
oh my god magnum's got no hp not like
this
sentinels they're gonna get the defuse
they've done it
sentinels are the masters to reykjavik
champions and they do it flawlessly they
didn't drop a single map
they have made history here because they
are the first
global champions in valorant history
fnatic nearly pushed him to the brink
but sentinels won in a
3-0 sweep and their shutout in the grand
finals means they went the entire
tournament without dropping a
single map people doubted sentinels from
the very moment they came together
their unimpressive past shouldn't have
led to incredible success
but at every turn they proved those
doubters wrong
and in the end doing that on the biggest
stage they'd ever seen
meant everything to them it's crazy man
we we made this
team over a year ago now and uh you know
there's a lot of doubt a lot of people
saying watch play this
and that but like this like proves to a
point that like don't let anyone else
tell you what you can or can't do
like don't let others decide your future
like we put the work in and it shows
we're here now
the grind never ends though now
sentinels have to defend their title
but things are gonna be different this
time because
they're the best goddamn valorant team
in the world
and everyone knows it now you do realize
after taking the victory like this uh on
land that you put a bit of a target on
your back now
for every future event so dapper i want
to hear from you what you have to say to
the rest of the valerian world out there
who's looking to come for you
you know good luck we're just going to
get better
next is nile discord esports
yeah so my my question is actually for
dapper specifically
um i i spoke to you earlier uh just
before you left for iceland and you told
me that you were gonna continue your
your kind of bm play style up against
your some of your opponents
and now that you've played on lan i i
just have to ask
uh how does it feel tea bagging on lan
what's the hit edge like on some of
those t-bags
yeah so the tea bag it's more fluid uh
you just feel like you're kind of
immersed when you do it so it just makes
it feel ten times better
when you finally do it